public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente jean
marie le guen le secrétaire d'état aux
relations avec le parlement est l'invité
de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir soi et
merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec les
échos radio classique et l' agence
france-presse
trois grandes questions au programme
d'abord est ce la fin des réformes
jusqu'en 2017 pascal programme des échos
vous posera la question
ensuite françois hollande va t'il
s'incliner devant emmanuel macron qui
réunit ses supporters ce soir à
strasbourg et qui a le vent en poupe
aussillon d'après les sondages marquent
réel de la fp vous interrogera sur la
présidentielle est également sur la
primaire donc enfin troisième question
dire qu'avec la droite ce serait pire
est ce suffisant mickels à metz de
public sénat nous rejoindra enfin pour
aborder ce thème donc votre argument que
l'on entend à gauche en tous les cas
depuis quelques temps maintenant mais
d'abord jean marie le guen une question
d'actualité
la mobilisation pour sauver alstom à
belfort l'état commande donc des tgv
pour les utiliser comme intercités
c'est-à-dire à petite vitesse s absurde
non pas à petite vitesse à vitesse
normale à deux vitesses mais non ce
n'est pas absurde ce qui est absurde
c'est que nous avons une industrie
nationale des chemins de fer qui est
soumise aujourd'hui à des aléas de
circonstance et dire que nous savons
qu'à partir de 2020 il y aura un
programme de charge très important très
important et il faut disent ils à
conserver des compétences de l'activité
et donc s'avérer sursis qui a été
décidée aujourd'hui avec le segment
industrie c'est un plan industriel
global
vous avez peut-être pris déjà en plus
ces trains corail mais qu'ils sont et
bordeaux nice en l'occurrence c'est à
dire c'est un voyage important et qui
est fait dans des conditions aujourd'hui
qui sont tout à fait lamentable donc je
pense qu'il ya une amélioration de la
qualité et il ya en même temps la mise
sous tension de notre filière
industrielle
donc je pense que c'est un compromis
intelligent entre la capacité le
maintien d'une capacité industrielle
l'amélioration du service à la clientèle
et la résolution d'un problème
économique et social compromis
intelligent qui a un coût et plus d'un
demi milliard même près près d'un
milliard sur certaines estimations
donc pour sauver 400 emplois qui n'était
pas menacé jean marie le guen simplement
qu'ils risquaient d'être déplacé en
alsace je comprends la difficulté pour
les gens sur place mais est ce
raisonnable mais bien évidemment
présenté comme ça ça ne serait pas mais
ce n'est pas la réalité ce qui est la
réalité c'est le maintien et la
reconfiguration puisque vous parlez de
dans le détail de ce qui peut se passer
à alstom belfort c'est une
reconfiguration complète de lusine de
belfort
c'est le maintien de compétences qui
aurait fait défaut en 2020 et qu'ils
auraient à à ce moment-là a mené à ce
que eh bien on soit obligé d'importer en
quelque sorte d'être intense et oui déjà
malheureusement la sncf on l'a vu c'est
d'ailleurs de cette affaire les sims
être sncf dans une filiale dans une
filiale commune
soyons précis un jeu c'est pas la sncf
ces îles la filiale commune de la sncf
et de la deutsche bahn c'est à dire
sncf allemande pour un train
particuliers ont fait à l'appel d'offres
que malheureusement alstom n'a pas
remporté ce qui pose d'ailleurs le
problème aussi delà du fait que cette
entreprise doit aussi se remettre en
question je veux dire au moment où je
vous parle je vous dis il s'agit pas de
suppléer les défauts d'une entreprise de
sa compétitivité de son adaptation au
marché
par exemple si une entreprise qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la gamme tgv mais
qui a assez peu travaillé sur les gammes
intermédiaires
donc il y à une remise en cause cette
entreprise ses dirigeants doivent aussi
ne pas toujours attendre effectivement
que l'état soit si j'ose dire là dès la
prise pression mais un tout à fait mais
je le premier ministre la faire nous
pensons pas que l'état
puisse en permanence se niant ouais mais
justement aujourd'hui il ya un effort
des pouvoirs publics nous demandons à
l'entreprise de s'adapter à cet effort
est-ce que vous ne donnez pas le beau
rôle puisque là encore le premier
ministre a répété que c'était une action
de l'état stratège mais beaucoup
d'observateurs est compris dans votre
camp enfin benoît hamon dit plutôt que
c'est un étape politique qui essaye de
sauver les meubles dans la
présidentielle j'ai benoît hamon sur ce
sujet comme sur d'autres auraient
peut-être pu faire réfléchir un petit
peu à ce qu'il disait et a été tirée
contre son propre camp ça devient une
manie mais au-delà de l'aspect politique
des choses lorsque moi j'ai entendu
pendant dix ans que le rafale
c'était quelque chose qui était qui
n'existait que par les commandes de
l'état d'accord pendant 10 ans on a
entendu que ça une certaine presse des
commentateurs du gel rafale n'arrive pas
à le vendre mais pourquoi l'état dépense
est aujourd'hui en place domaines
stratégiques de l'armée et de la défense
est ce que le ferroviaire
ça descend l'agencé en agissant de la
fir français de l'industrie ce que ce
n'est pas stratégique
nous avons fait régulièrement ce
gouvernement a fait ce qu'il devait en
matière industrielle
nous avons sauvé stx nous avons sauvé
psa nous avons encouragé les entreprises
comme renault et comme michelin qui
viennent de dons vous refusez le procès
contre l'industrie
sauve qui peu avant la présidence et les
commentaires faciles c'est la réalité
c'est que nous sauvons dans l'industrie
l'industrie c'est quoi c'est pas
simplement des emplois et bien sûr vous
aviez raison de dire que les 400 emplois
c'est important mais c'est pas
simplement ça la création de valeur
ajoutée sur le territoire national la
capacité de garder des compétences
scientifiques et technologiques
c'est ça l'enjeu pendant toutes les
années 2000 les dix premières années on
a perdu plus de cinq cent mille emplois
industriels
aujourd'hui ça s'arrête vous avez un
article dans les échos ce matin les
échos dans les maintenant dans le monde
c'est après midi nous avons stoppé
l'hémorragie industrielle de ce pays et
nous n'allons pas bien voilà et cette
dernière question c'est ce que nous
mettrons est-ce que vous avez des
inquiétudes sur le dossier alstom
vis-à-vis de bruxelles qui pourrait
trouver à redire à cette aide c'est
achat direct de l'état un sans appel
d'offres est-ce que vous avez d une
inquiétude là
non pas pas d'inquiétude non blanches
sont très claires il est de la
responsabilité de l'état de passer
commande il le fait il le fait de façon
stratégique
pas d'inquiétude dernière question est
ce que vous redoutez une vague de plans
sociaux mais après la présidentielle est
ce que certains sont un peu mis sous le
tapis en ce moment comme celle inverse
c'est la coutume saint-just bien non
mais la coutume dont c'était le cas oui
c'est exact avant si je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est plutôt confronté à
une série d'industriels qui veulent
peut-être profiter du climat pour
essayer de trouver des solutions de se
débarrasser de problème donc je je je
constate que healy a sans arrêt
lorsqu'on est comme les christophe
sirugue ministre de l'industrie du
travail parce que la théorie selon
laquelle le marché résoudre et tout est
une théorie fausse qui a mis notre pays
et l'europe peut-être d'ailleurs souvent
à genoux nous avons besoin d'un état
stratège nous avons besoin d'une europe
qui n'est pas naïve dans sa construction
de sa politique industrielle
c'est ce que nous faisons et c'est ce
que nous allons continuer à faire ça ne
veut pas dire que l'état peut tout vous
voyez je reprends cette formule non
l'état il a créé un écosystème va
d'ailleurs il est contre-productif
ça t'arrive ça peut arriver arrive et
oui bien sûr une état n'est pas un
magicien mais il est là aussi pour aider
les entreprises et les entreprises elles
mêmes par exemple dans le domaine même
delà des nouvelles technologies de
l'innovation
il est inexact de dire que le marché
peut tous y a pas une intervention de
l'état pour créer non pas avec une
vision étatique contre le privé mais au
contraire dans une liaison public privé
trouver véritablement là l'hybridation
des politiques rivales dans des
politiques industrielles ses trajets
ribordy nous accueillons maintenant
pascal programme des échos il nous
rejoint pour et la première question
l'émission bonjour l'épreuve de vérité
avec ray du classique et les échos
pascal bonsoir bonsoir jean marie le
guen soir avant d'en venir aux dernières
initiatives du quinquennat je voulais
revenir encore un petit peu sur le
sauvetage annoncé lui du site alstom de
belfort
15-15 tgv acheté en propre par le
gouvernement selon les estimations ça
fait 450 millions d'euros 500 millions
d'euros où trouve-t-on cette somme
écoutez le ministre du budget va le
faire il y avait des plans de charge qui
était d'ores et déjà prévu s'agissant du
réseau intercités dont vous parlez je
vous êtes bien d'accord avec moi pour
dire que la responsabilité de ce réseau
revenait à l'état et non pas la sncf
1 c'est bien ça dont il s'agit donc il y
avait déjà des sommes qui avait été
provisionnée qui seront mobilisés et les
efforts financiers de l'état seront mis
en oeuvre
je vais vous avez raison à chaque fois
de nous poser la question dès qu'il y à
une mesure audi a d'ailleurs quand on la
prend pas en dit c'est scandaleux l'état
est impuissant quand une fois qu'on l'a
pris en dit assez bien mais où est ce
que vous avez trouvé l'argent et bien
l'argent jusqu'à présent nous l'avons
toujours trouver toujours trouver chaque
année depuis on nous fait le procès de
du financement des mesures
chaque année nos prévisions étaient
respectées et s'agissant des finances
publiques
elles ont même été améliorée puisque
comme vous le savez nous sommes en deçà
de ce qui avait été prévu en termes de
résultats du déficit public en
l'occurrence si je pose cette question
jean marie le guen sait que parmi les
nombreuses critiques qui ont été
formulées sur le budget 2010 est
présentée la semaine dernière c'est
qu'un certain nombre de dépenses
n'apparaissent pas dans ce projet de loi
de finances je pense notamment aux
milliards qui ont et qu'ils vont être
mobilisés pour le renflouement d'areva
des dépenses qui n'apparaissent pas dans
le plf
ça vous a été reproché une dépense telle
que celle qui est annoncée aujourd'hui
pour pour sauver le site d'alstom
alstom de belfort n'apparaîtra pas non
plus par définition dans le plf on a le
sentiment qu avant même d'être débattu à
l'assemblée
le budget est en décalage avec la
réalité vous ne confondons pas ce qui
est le budget le fonctionnement de
l'état terra et des dépenses qui sont
des dépenses un peu de nature
exceptionnelle en matière de politique
industrielle
nous avons deux
la marge il y a aussi le programme
d'investissements d'avenir pour partie
il y a aussi tout un tas de fond qui
concerne nous avons des actifs l'état à
des actifs en matière de politique
industrielle
donc il peut jouer sur ces actifs
également après le budget effectivement
qu était présentée la semaine dernière
était fortement dénoncé décrié comme un
budget en trompe l'oeil et et parmi les
critiques il ya quand même le premier
président de la cour des comptes didier
migaud qui dit avec son style son
scepticisme notamment sur le chiffre de
la croissance mais celui temps les côtes
pour l'année 2016 le haut conseil
considère que la prévision de croissance
du gouvernement de hun sen qui est un
peu élevé au regard des informations
connues à ce jour ils notent qu'elle est
supérieur à la plupart des prévisions
publiées récemment un roulier réagir par
avance très simple presque l'année
dernière qui avait raison de la
publication d'une de la prévision du
gouvernement ou ceux du haut conseil des
finances publiques je vous pose la
question je me souviens plus loin voilà
vous voyez donc je ne vais pas être très
important si ça l'est parce qu'en
l'occurrence
oui j'en viens à ce qui était le thème
de ceux de cette séquence sur les
réformes
on est aujourd'hui à sept mois de
l'élection présidentielle on sent bien
que l'exécutif et et tourner totalement
vers cette échéance électorale
le sentiment qu'on a que j'aime mais en
tout cas c'est que plus aucun dossier
d'importance ne sera lancée d'ici au
mois d'avril d'ici au mois de mai est ce
que je me trompe
attendez yade 3 secondes en parler d'
alstom ce n'est pas un dossier à leurs
adhérents
donc le programme législatif il ya
malheureusement le secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
que je suis complètement bouquet comme
on dit et nous avons un travail un plan
de charge qui est très important bon
encore cet après midi une réforme
extrêmement importante va être mis sur
pied qui est celle de la réforme des
masters jeudi sa chute le mot le mot
sélection de le mot sélection il peut
sortir de votre bouche quand même jean
marie le guen l'occurrence mais j'ai
aucun problème avec ça alors éprouvé
aucun nom et c'est une sélection avec
des droits c'est quelque chose qui est
intelligent c'est à dire que
effectivement il n'est pas dit ce qui
était le cas précédemment c'est que
n'importe qui est supposé faire
n'importe quel master quelles que soient
ses résultats quelle que soit sa
formation initiale mais a contrario il
est dit que toute personne qui veut
faire un master 2 en l'occurrence c'est
à dire la cinquième et la sixième année
pour de fac je dis ça pour tous ceux qui
sont pas les les adeptes des formations
universitaires bien pourra le faire en
lui proposant fera des propositions à
l'étudiant qui correspondent réellement
à son niveau donc il y a plus qu'une
orientation non pas une sélection
couperet effectivement mais c'est une
réforme qui est très importante elle est
fondamentale pour l'université française
je crois que un journal comme le vôtre
l'a souvent souligné ben voilà voyez ça
tombe aujourd'hui je peux pas je
pourrais encore égrainé
récemment l'objectif c'est de c'est
d'avoir un master réformes et à la
rentrée 2010 est ce à dire qu'il faut
aller vite quel sera le vecteur de cette
de cette renault en discute encore il ya
plusieurs possibilités
je pense qu'il y aura il ya une ppl
sénatoriale qui est
d'ailleurs porté par un sénateur ring
oui de la majorité sénatoriale donc de
l'opposition nationale qui devrait
permettre d'accrocher cette réforme
la ppl été beaucoup plus modeste mais on
a un temps parlementaire qui nous
permettra d'avancer ces séquences c'est
très important
vraiment merci votre question sur les
réformes j'en ai d'autres
alors il est un sujet qui est dans l'air
du temps qui monte qui ne fait pas
encore l'objet d'art d'un projet
législatif c'est le revenu universel
le premier ministre manuel valls en a
parlé le week-end dernier encore en
appelant
l'ouverture d'un débat sur le sujet ça
typiquement c'est une réforme d'ampleur
qu'on n'imagine pas lancée avant le
avant le printemps
c'est plus un thème de campagne oui
c'est une armée c'est même une réflexion
stratégique sur la société gea soyons
très très zen est bien sûr alors il y à
une première marche vous savez une
marche qui est fou fait en ce moment par
le gouvernement qui est de simplifier de
rassembler les différents minima sociaux
c'est une première étape de
simplification mais la question
fondamentale du revenu universel
c'est une réforme de société absolument
colossal qui ne se décide pas en
appuyant sur un bouton ni dans un projet
de loi de finances ni même soyons très
honnête par un engagement présidentiel
qui dirait ah ben non alors que on a etc
ont d'abord eu moi je pense qu'il faut
discuter de ce genre de choses je pense
que ce que fait le premier ministre sait
qui pose sur la table une question
essentielle qui a à voir avec la
solidarité mais qui a à voir aussi avec
une réflexion beaucoup plus fondamentale
sur le travail à 5 ou à 10 ans nous
avons connu la révolution d'internet ces
dernières années nous connaîtrons une
deuxième révolution d'internet vous le
savez le big data la connectique la
robotique et bien cela nous amène à
réfléchir à de nouveaux outils à une
nouvelle approche de l'emploi et du
travail parmi la palette mais outre la
en parle ici
lissine aide universelle pour bien qu'il
ait bien vient chargement il fait qu'on
voit bien que c'est exactement ça le
sujet c'est à dire qu'il va falloir
réfléchir à une nouvelle approche des
parcours professionnel dans lequel le
revenu universel serait un filet de
sécurité tout à fait essentiel on parle
d'une seule voix au sein du ps sur ce
sur ce sujet ont dit non non non pas de
vineuil ça serait dommage qu'on parle
que d'une seule voix en l'occurrence on
le premier ministre est celui qui en
parlent le plus nettement
mais encore une fois il va falloir en
débattre parce que enfin je vais pas si
vous voulez on peut rentrer dans les
éléments techniques mais est ce que
c'est un revenu universel qui est déj
d'abord comme on le met en oeuvre
est-ce qu'on le mette en oeuvre de façon
expérimentale où est-ce qu'on
l'appliquent d'une façon générale est-ce
qu'on l'appliquent d'abord at elle une
catégorie de la population je pense aux
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans ou est ce qu'on le
fait pour tout le monde quelle est la
part des revenus je peux continuer les
questions posées elles sont tout à fait
fondamentale est-ce qu'on fait
disparaître toutes les autres
allocations ou bien on ne les fait pas
disparaître
c'est là qu'est ce qu'il ya les
économies surtout parce que d'abord est
ce qu'on vise des économies parce que la
france dépense énormément par rapport à
sa création de richesses dans l'aide
sociale qui lui permet effectivement
d'avoir à la différence de tous les
autres pays
oui des couches moyennes qui reste
encore des couches moyennes c'est aussi
je vous renvoie au rapport du conseil
économique et social et environnemental
c'est très clairement nous sommes un des
rares pays développés qui ces cinq
dernières années qui savent parce que
comme on parle souvent de l'est et vous
passez sous fin pas vous personnellement
mais les commentateurs parlent de la
description d'une misère absolue dans
laquelle serait la france et de l'autre
côté dans la gabegie total dans lequel
seraient ses finances publiques et
sociales en l'occurrence je dis
simplement que le conseil économique et
social et environnemental a bien montré
combien la france était un des rares
pays développés qui gardait encore un
corps de couches moyennes et les couches
moyennes
c'est pas simplement beaucoup de nos
compatriotes c'est aussi une des
garanties de la démocratie car vos
sujets de campagne
quelques sur le sujet de projets de
société quelques mots sur l'assurance
chômage on sait que les partenaires
sociaux n'ont pas réussi à se mettre
d'accord au début de l'été sur une
nouvelle convention unedic
la balle est maintenant dans le camp du
gouvernement quels sont les scénarios
sur la table
le premier ministre a dit qu'on
réfléchit à plusieurs pistes mais
d'abord il faut il faudrait vérifier que
les partenaires sociaux certes ils ont
échoué vous avez raison avant l'été mais
qui ne sont pas à même et qu'il souhaite
même se débarrasser du problème ou lieu
où plus électeurs ne pas le traiter pour
être plus objectif
bon
s'il était vérifier qu'ils ne sont pas
en état de traiter le problème est
effectivement je vais ça fait partie des
questions sous jacentes du fait que le
gouvernement a décidé des choses tout à
fait stratégique encore
et il réformer jusqu'au bout il faudra
effectivement réformer l'assurance
chômage parmi les pistes y en a
plusieurs qui sont sur la table
vous les connaissez elles sont pas
arbitrées si j'en cite une on va dire
tout de suite que c'est déjà arbitré ce
qui n'est pas le cas mais il ya eu
toujours favorable à une éventuelle
dégressivité des allocations chômage
vous nous aviez dit ici oui mais parce
que j'étais né oui dans certaines
conditions ne soyons pas trop simpliste
et par exemple je pense qu'il faudrait
distinguer les gens qui ont une carrière
longue à l'intérieur d'une entreprise et
les gens qui ont une carrière courte
mais c'est un avis personnel qui fera
partie de la discussion évidemment il ya
aussi je m'étais aussi prononcé pour la
taxation des contrats courts bien je
pense que c'est moi je pense que c'est
une idée intéressante je sais que en bon
si elle devait être plus ou moins
compensée par une certaine forme de
baisse de la taxation des contrats longs
ça aboutirait à sortes de choses mais ça
là vous me faites parler en tant que
responsable politique je l'accueille
revient volontiers c'est pas le membre
du gouvernement qui parle en
l'occurrence exemple mais le calendrier
tel que vous le sentez ce serait ce
sujet là serait sur la table à acquérir
des origines et je crois qu'un petit peu
de temps michel encore une dernière une
agression une disposition technique qui
devrait apparaître dans le collectif
budgétaire en décembre qui est le conte
entrepreneurs investisseurs une
disposition qui est porté notamment par
axel le maire je résume rapidement
l'idée c'est de permettre à des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont vendu les parts de
leur entreprise d'investir dans des
start up innovantes et d'avoir et de
réduire leur impôt en investissant de la
sorte
pourquoi ne pas avoir proposé sa
disposition dans le cadre du budget 2010
est est ce que vous aviez peur de
réveiller la les frondeurs sur un sujet
comme celui là je pense que c'est une
progression
écoutez enfin j'espère que non j'espère
qu'ils seraient ils seront pas contre
c'est une mesure tout à fait fondamental
il a réclamé par les pigeons je le fais
une c'est une mesure tout à fait
fondamentale qui permet me semble-t-il
de réinvestir la richesse française dans
l'investissement productif
singulièrement dans les startups donc je
suis tout à fait favorable à cette
mesure
elle est simplement techniquement elle
sera elle doit être finalisée c'est pour
ça qu'elle sera dans ce deuxième texte
de loi de finances que non vous parler
une dernière question vous avez parlé du
sauvetage d'alstom l'industrie
pharmaceutique s'alarme des mesures
d'économie imposées dans le budget de la
sécurité sociale
une mécanique de rabot 1 milliards 7
attendu est ce que vous demandez trop
laboratoire au risque là de faire
vraiment disparaître des emplois dans
pas mal de sites en france c'est la
menace des laboratoires vous qui êtes
médecin et connaissez bien oui budget de
la sécu par ailleurs non je pense qu'ils
savent très bien les laboratoires qu'il
y a
des diminutions de prix et de volumes
qui sont attendus il y a par ailleurs
d'autres éléments d'une politique du
médicament sire que la sécurité sociale
n'est pas là simplement pour payer
l'industrie pharmaceutique est là
d'autres fonctions c'est notamment de
rembourser des soins utiles aux français
par ailleurs il est légitime que
l'industrie se poser nous pose des
problèmes en matière de stratégie
industrielle et il faut que la france
c'est vrai reste un site de production
de recherche bien sûr de développement
et de production de 2000 aux médicaments
je pense notamment à tous les
biosimilaires enfin bref il ya des il y
à il ya eu du retard industriel en
france par exemple nous avons pris du
retard sur en matière de médicaments sur
ce qui était tout les biotech et bien il
faut rattraper ce retard non seulement
dans la recherche là on est plutôt bon
mais aussi dans la production
merci pascal de la fp arrive maintenant
pour la seconde partie de l'épreuve de
vérité
l'épreuve de vérité avec la fp
bon cela marque bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
le ministre alors les mauvais sondages
s'accumulent pour le président le
chômage la situation économique ne
montrent pas de signes de redressement
c'est même plutôt l'inversé dernières
semaines et on voit qu emmanuel macron
apparaît désormais comme le mieux placé
en tout cas face au président de la
république est ce que françois hollande
va renoncer face à la candidature
possible probable des manuels macron
alors là vous déjà vous êtes dans
l'anticipation complète avec des si si
si si si j'ai beaucoup de si donc moi je
serais très si vous le permettez
beaucoup plus pragmatique je dis
simplement aujourd'hui que j'ai bien
noté que nous avions et que le président
la république avait un rapport à
l'opinion qu'ils étaient aujourd'hui
difficile nous sommes engagés dans un
travail qui commence à mon avis à se
faire entendre
qui est ce que je pourrais appeler la
réhabilitation de ce que nous avons fait
moi je le dis aux gens de gauche les
yeux dans les yeux et très clairement
nous n'avons pas à baisser la tête
devant ce que nous avons réalisé ces
commença par leur élan avec moi d'abord
il faut dire un socle parce que on est
dans le holland bashing on est dans le
socialo bashing depuis maintenant des
mois et des mois etc et on n'y a d'autre
part de responsabilité à la fois parce
qu'on n'a pas été forcément des bons
pédagogues et deuxièmement parce qu'une
partie de la gauche passe son temps à
nous casser du sucre sur le dos mais la
réalité c'est que le seul pays développé
où la lutte contre la pauvreté a
progressé ces cinq dernières années
c'est la france
la réalité on en parlait à l'instant
c'est que l'allemagne est le seul pays
développé où les couches moyennes se
sont à peu près maintenu à un certain
niveau
c'est la france le chômage de ce pays en
europe nom ne vous dit pas n'importe
quoi seul pays en europe ya un pays qui
fait nettement mieux que nous c'est
l'allemagne pour des raisons de
politique industrielle dont on pourrait
tout à fait parler et qu'ils méritent
d'ailleurs qui nous interpellent et
c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça et c'est
pour ça que nous avons mis en place une
politique qui fait en sorte de limiter
les coûts salariaux et que nous avons un
coût du travail qui aujourd'hui est
inférieur à celui de l'allemagne c'est
pour ça que nous avons rétabli les
marges des entreprises qui avait été
beaucoup abîmé à la suite de la crise de
2008 tout ça nous le faisons
avec un respect des finances publiques
et avec aussi au respect du modèle
social c'est comme ça c'est le temps du
bilan et nous n'avons nous avons bien
l'intention de défendre ce bilan
réhabilite avec la réhabilitation du
bilan avec en prenant acte évidemment de
nos erreurs de nos insuffisances ceci
est très claire deuxièmement j'irai très
vite là dessus bien que ce soit aux
oreilles de tous les français parce que
on est aujourd'hui en pleine campagne
des primaires à droite et on voit bien
ce que propose la droite ce que nous
avons fait ce que nous proposons est
donc il y a aussi une comparaison et
ceux qui ont glosé vaurien invité il ya
six mois ya un an il ya deux ans n'ont
rien dit mais alors la droite et la
gauche c'est la même chose bas au moins
maintenant vous avez pu me poser la
question d'ailleurs vous me la posent et
pas parce que quand il ya le programme
de la droite qui est mise d les voilà
troisièmement il faudra un projet il
faudrait une incarnation le président la
république je vous réponds et de mon
point de vue le mieux placé pour à la
fois apporter ce que je viens de dire
est allé j'entends bien que emmanuel
macron par exemple aujourd'hui parce que
il y à un concours de circonstances
d'abord c'est une personnalité de
qualité ça a été un très bon ministre
deuxièmement il semble vouloir
s'abstraire des comment tirer acheter
pesanteurs qui est de gauche qui est de
droite il semble aussi être relativement
peu précis encore sur les engagements
qui sont les siens et ceux ci correspond
il dresse le diagnostic et en durée
d'écouté chez moi ça m'intéresse toute
façon je suis intéressé par par part
justement ce travail intellectuel
j'espère qu'il va être produit j'espère
qu'il sera de qualité et j'espère qu'il
servira de notre pays et la gauche
d'une façon générale mais vous parlez
comme de lui en disant c'est un concours
de circonstances qui se retrouve le
mieux placé il est aujourd'hui en je
pense si vous voulez je ne pense pas que
je ne fais pas de procès d'intention
je constate que sur ce je constate qu'il
n'a pas produit pour l'instant les
éléments politiques qu'ils fassent qu'à
mon avis la démarche qui est la sienne
soit crédible et durable
voilà maintenant je peux en j'attends
d'être
comme on démontre le contraire
idéologiquement vous êtes quand même
assez proche de lui vous pourriez le
soutenir à l'avenir mais moi j'ai
toujours soutenu j'étais un réformiste
je suis animateur du pôle réformiste je
l'avais invité une autre université
d'été à pessac léognan j'ai des nuances
jeu par exemple je suis pas socialisée
râle je suis quelqu'un qui est sur une
position effectivement pour entreprise
je crois mais je pense que l'état a un
rôle je pense que le régalien comme on
dit aujourd'hui un rôle et je ne suis
pas dans cette mission des nuances mais
et des nuances que que j'apprécie et et
donc il peut être tout à fait utile il
peut être utile il peut être tout à fait
dommageable à la gauche il peut détruire
la gauche comme l'a dit manuel valls en
bas et oui si si sa candidature
s'avérait être une candidature qui fait
que la gauche ne peut pas être la gauche
deux responsabilités
moi je pense qu'il faut la clarification
de ce point de vue je suis d'accord avec
lui faut une clarification politique la
gauche
aujourd'hui il ya une gauche dans le
monde entier qui est de la gauche de
l'indignation et qui refuse d'assumer
les responsabilités et ça donne
l'effondrement du parti travailliste en
grande-bretagne
ça donne le pse et et podemos qui n'a
d'autre objet que de faire que monsieur
rajoy soit à nouveau investie en espagne
ça donne
la critique de monsieur de sipera ce
après que monsieur tsipras cette avancée
on le critique et on l'affaiblît dans la
dure gestion qui est la sienne en france
bref bref donc la france je pas besoin
de rappeler ce que les épisodes
douloureux que nous avons connue depuis
des années avec ses soi-disant frondeur
et donc cette gauche-là qui ne veut pas
gouverner elle nous pose problème et je
pense que il faut une clarification
c'est à dire moi je suis soit français
je dis aux électeurs de gauche
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est qu'on voit
bien les enjeux ils sont fondamentaux
n'oublions pas l'extrême droite qui est
à 30% et qui sera vraisemblablement un
adversaire qui n'est pas battu d'avancé
au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle battu d'avancé
elle n'est pas battu d'avancé ce qu'ils
pensent
ceux qui pensent jeu soyons très précis
que il n'y a aucune chance et qu'il n'y
a aucun danger du côté de l'extrême
droite se trompe lourdement
et je la croisais perdre contre marine
le pen à gauche la droite peuvent perdre
contre auvergne c'est pour ça que moi
j'appelle au dépassement de la gauche et
j'appelle à une recomposition politique
qui fasse que nous rassemblions les
républicains parce que je crois que s'il
n'y a pas un rassemblement des
républicains alors effectivement une
droite sectaire une gauche sectaire
peuvent perdre face à marine le arrête
vous vous disiez justement que la
candidature d'emmanuel mâcon pouvait
détruire la gauche dans le sens où elle
la priverait peut-être d'un axe d'un
nenê ses rares chances d'accès aux
seconds tours mais mme emmanuelle bach
on pourrait vous inversez la réflexion
il pourra dire finalement françois
hollande va m'empêcher possiblement
d'avoir des chances d'être au second
tour et c'est moi le mieux placé des
deux donc ça lui de sortie oui mais
d'abord je d'abord on peut toujours
spéculer comme ça mais d'abord je pense
que pour l'instant il ne s'est pas
rattachée à la gauche je ne dis pas que
lui même n'est pas de gauche mais parce
que je ne dis pas je nie pour l'instant
sa démarche il ne l'a pas placé dans un
renouvellement à gauche c'est une déjà
une nuance que j'ai avec lui moi je ne
suis pas pour l'immobilisme
je pense que l'immobilisme conduit la
gauche dans le mur mais je pense que ce
renouveau il s'adresse à la gauche qu'il
faut prendre la gauche qu'il faut
prendre le corps de la gauche et le
maître et le mettre à la hauteur des
événements et des responsabilités qui
sont les nôtres
je ne suis pas pour partir de la gauche
je ne suis pas pour déserter le terrain
de la gauche c'est ce qu'il fallait
je pense que pour l'instant il ne s'est
pas positionné c'est un danger j'attends
j'attends qu'il se positionne mais a par
ailleurs il attire un certain nombre de
2,2 de souhaits d'aspiration de soutien
et ses soutiens peuvent parfois manche
il manquait à la gauche réformiste que
je souhaite mettre en avant et donc il y
a il ya effectivement un danger la
stratégique et qui est la sienne n'est
pas neutre c'est pas une stratégie sans
conséquence en 8c un danger vous l'avez
dit donc essayer de dire des choses est
un danger dont la conclusion c'était
cela a atteint compris c'est on a suivi
le fil de votre réflexion jamais régaté
j c'est pas lui c'est sa stratégie était
d'accord
branchez la même chose en tous les cas
il est arrivé tout à l'heure à
strasbourg
si vous êtes en danger c'est pas la même
chose c'est sympa que percevront qu'il
en soit personne ne croit il est arrivé
tout à l'heure à strasbourg il ya déjà
du monde sur le quai de gare évidemment
est d'emblée il a réagi à manuel valls
qui l'accusent de représenter une forme
de populisme lite on écoute la réponse
d'emmanuel macron ou ce qui me mine east
il a redit des commentaires critiques
étaient connus je parle aux gens et je
les écoute
je ne crois pas que ça s'appelle du
populisme
la démocratie alors c'était le mode trop
populisme non il veut le premier mari
faisait référence populisme light
référence à un positionnement qui a été
effectivement ni gauche ni droite ce qui
est toujours un tout petit peu moi je
suis pour le dépassement jeu plus acteur
je suis pour le dépassement de la gauche
je ne suis pas pour le fait qu'on résume
la vie politique à la gauche et à la
droite j'ai parlé de l'extrême droite
chez parler de la france donc il est
légitime de vouloir dépasser mais
dépassé ça ne veut pas dire nier et là
j'ai un désaccord sur ce nigaud ch ni
droite je pense que c'est à la fois
inexact ça n'existe pas et c'est
effectivement un tout petit peu
dangereux deuxièmement lorsqu'il tient
un certain type de discours où il balaye
dieu sait que je suis un des plus
critiques vis-à-vis de ma propre
formation politique je vais pas de
sujets là dessus je crois qu'on peut
m'en donnait ac mais je pense néanmoins
que les partis politiques aussi fragile
soit il aussi vieilli soit il participe
quand même de la démocratie donc je ne
crois pas concret une démarche politique
sans lien avec les partis les
associations les syndicats
je crois à cela donc c'est là où je dis
attention
vouloir tout balayer vouloir tout
construire sur une table rase ça
s'appelle du populisme lie donc manuel
valls a raison
dedans l'occurrence je pense qu'il a
raison de cibler une petite facilité
d'accord dans la démarche des manuels
mac on nous avait dit que emmanuel
macron vous n'avez pas encore produit
quelque chose de crédible et de durable
il ya un instant jean marie noëlle mais
quand on écoute ses proches en tous les
cas ce qui s'exprime dans la presse
l'idée c'est pas forcément veut
construire un programme détaillé ils
vont pas faire mille pages mais c'est de
construire une campagne sur la volonté
un peu comme kennedy face à nixon
figurez vous c'est une belle ambition on
l'encouragé un peu quand même
non mais faut faire des progrès c'est
autre chose que de dire regardez
je vais essayer de ressembler avec les
mets dans la politique moderne il faut
faire des promesses précises où il faut
être vague et après on navigue à vue en
disant on fixe pour la logique dit si
votre question est précise donc je ne
suis je crois que c'est un dévoiement de
l'élection présidentielle que de faire
des catalogues de promesses et c'est
d'ailleurs un des problèmes de la
démocratie que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui je vous réponds donc très
clairement non par contre il faut donner
des axes faut pas donner des maux
verbeux il ya un moment il faut dire un
certain nombre de choses qui on est et
où on va comme on le fait avec qui on le
fait ça ça a du sens voilà on peut pas
rester on peut on n'est pas obligé de
dire combien de rames de tgv on va
acheter mais on peut dire ça c'est bon
pour le gouvernement c'est pas bon pour
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
mais on doit donner du sens politique de
la puissance politique et ça c'est un
sens quand on décrit un avenir quand on
parle de la vie des français des
inégalités qui existent dans ce pays
alors on peut se projeter
on peut dire avec qui on fait quelque
chose ce que l'on veut faire qu'à
l'europe on veut quel type de rapport à
la laïcité on veut ça c'est des
questions que l'on pose rond merci marc
c'est terminé pour vous je suis pour
l'instant c'est michael aimait ce qui
vient pour la troisième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité
sans michel roussin jean marie le guen
alors dire qu'avec la droite serait pire
peut-il suffire
en fait nous nous refaites l'histoire de
quelque chose qu'on connaît bien
regarder c'est en 86 regarder cette
affiche de campagne
attention la droite revient et c'est le
remake de ce qu'on a connu à 86 ça je
crois que vous alliez la montre et c'est
pour ça excusez-moi nom puisqu'elle
était traité rigoles attentes
alors non non c'est on n'est plus du
tout dans la même situation
d'abord parce que c'est pas moi ce que
je dis simplement j'ai parlé du bilan
jeudi comparez vous savez c'est leclerc
à l'éprît vous prenez votre achat vous
comparez voilà vous avez le comparateur
de prix tous les gens d'accord
aujourd'hui ont l'habitude de comparer
je leur demande qu'une seule chose moi
je leur dis pas attention je leur dis
attention regardez bien ce qui est écrit
regardez bien ce qu'ils disent et faites
votre choix
voilà donc je ne dis pas olala j'ai peur
jeudi les français doivent savoir très
clairement ce qu'ils vont peut-être ou
pas décidé en mai prochain et je dis que
dans le débat démocratique
la gauche et la droite ça veut dire
quelque chose alors qu'eux mêmes je
demande un dépassement de cet as de
cette opposition revenir sur ce départ à
la baisse des prestations sociales
assumées par nicolas sarkozy retraite à
65 ans réforme du code du travail et
bien d'autres choses
assumez là aussi par alain juppé la
france est au courant et sap
ce qui va se passer si jamais la droite
devait revenir au pouvoir je pense que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya d'ailleurs
un petit peu dans notre débat nous tous
il ya un petit peu de
les françaises ont un grand scepticisme
et ils le doivent aux politiques et ils
ont ils compris le scepticisme des pro
master que pour beaucoup d'entre eux je
le crois aujourd'hui 1 ils n'ont pas
complètement lui comme vous et moi
les programmes on va pas leur en vouloir
c'est parfois un peu deuxièmement je
pense qu'il ya une sorte de scepticisme
de haut mais finalement ils disent ça
mais ils ne le feront pas bien je pense
que c'est peut- il faut un certain temps
cela va percolé voilà comme on dit
donc ça va perco l'état dira c'est à
dire je pense qu'il va y est il va y
avoir une prise de conscience que ce que
propose à droite est ce que propose la
gauche où ce que fait la gauche ça n'a
rien à voir
c'est des choses enfin c'est des choses
très différentes que le programme qui
est celui de la droite aujourd'hui est
un programme qui n'est pas simplement
une alternance comme on a pu connaître
mais qui est véritablement un je dirais
c'est un véritable je trouve je cherche
le mot mais véritablement une
déconstruction j'essaie de trouver un
mot qui ne soit pas trop facile et trop
brutale c'est une déconstruction
profonde on vous écoute vous y vont
ouvrir les portes de l'enfer c'est ce
que vous nous dites non écoutez moi je
veux moi je peux prendre toutes les
mesures ou plutôt que de rester dans le
flou alors je prends voilà lisf non
l'impôt sur les successions
monsieur sarkozy propose cinq cent mille
euros par français part par enfant ne
suis pas bon ça correspond je vous le
rappelle ils avaient propos nous avons
mis nous cent mille euros 95 % des
français ne sont plus concernés par
l'impôt sur les successions
ce dont parle monsieur sarkozy s'est
donc les 5 % des français les plus
riches
voilà ça coûte 5 milliards d'euros 5
milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire un point
de tva s'est opéré sonia ribes est 5 ça
c'est une mesure est une mesure non non
non ils ont besoin d'autres mesures on
peut courir mais aussi que ces cinq
milliards d'euros à cinq pour cent des
français
deuxièmement lisf l'impôt sur le revenu
je vais venir après l isf l'impôt sur le
revenu on dit 10 % 10 % s de 40
milliards c'est une un résultat non non
pas c'est l'ensemble qui fait 40 les
bien sûr sur l'impôt sur le revenu ces 7
milliards sur ces 7 milliards il ya 5
milliards à 10 % des français les plus
riches 10 % donc c'est la politique des
plus riches est ce que vous êtes entre
ces mais je les dis dès que monsieur
sarkozy a sorti son livre génie c'est
pas tout pour la france c'est tout pour
les riches et vous savez moi je les
autres s'alignent les zones c
nicolas sarkozy met un peu de choses
près au plan programmatique et au plan
fiscal et social c'est un peu de choses
près donc je prends les choses
moi vous savez on va jouer le check up
on prend les choses
oui exactement on n'arrête pas de dire
comme ça ils sont droits qui sont gauche
et c'est non
5 milliards d'euros 5 % les plus riches
recettes milliards d'euros 10% les
mairies de là ils vont vous répondre que
de toute façon votre politique fait que
les riches ils sont déjà plus en france
alors mais parlons du ca monsieur
grossiord mais c'est c'est d'ailleurs
c'est pas moi qui vais dire ce que je
vous dis c'est thierry breton qui était
ministre
pendant cinq ans des finances de jacques
chirac et de jean pierre raffarin qu'est
ce qui dit il dit ce que propose la
droite aujourd'hui en l'occurrence
monsieur sarkozy il était plus précis
c'est exactement ce qu'il a proposé en
2007 avec le projet tepa laissez-moi
terminer sur ce sujet a indiqué le
projet était pas c'était le bouclier
fiscal ça consistait à donner aux en
raison de ce que vous dites de l'argent
aux plus riches moins nettement que ce
qui est proposé cette fois ci il faut
dire que comme il a besoin de se
rattraper cette fois ci il fait des
chèques beaucoup plus lourd mais cela
aboutit à un an un augmentation avant la
crise de 2008 avant la crise de 2008 à
une rupture des engagements de la france
vis-à-vis de l'europe à une augmentation
considérable de la dette avant la crise
de 2008 qui a amené nos finances
publiques dans la situation où nous
sommes aujourd'hui est celle que l'on a
connue c'est à dire une augmentation une
augmentation de la dette publique
française de 500 milliards entre 2007 et
2012 et ceux ci étaient avant la crise
est ce que je dis là c'est thierry
breton qui le deal comprend grenouille
est fâché non non je suis pas du tout
fâché
j'essaye d'être précis parce que si on
résume votre propre arles
j'allais dire on va on s'envoyer des
images comme celles-là la droite revient
à la bougie
bien compris c'était très drôle de
servir encore des noms je pense que
justement c'est un petit peu oui mais on
n'est plus dans l'idéologie
moi je suis dans le faste chez king je
regarde les mesures je les prends je
vois à qui elles vont à quoi elle
correspond
est-ce que ça à ce que ça a un intérêt
économique est ce que la loi traitez pas
à créer de la croissance
non est ce que la loi de la caisse qu'à
créer la loi tepa de l'enrichissement
vous avec les récents ce vrai nous avons
fait de la croissance de façon
insuffisante
c'est exact mais alors la revenons-en
oui il ya eu
nous avons laissé partir en 2012 et 2013
des éléments de fiscalité qui était
erroné qui étaient exagérées sur lequel
nous sommes revenus depuis en grande
partie bien est-ce que ça a eu des
conséquences négatives vraisemblablement
en tout cas au plan politique c'est
clair mais donc là dessus oui il ya eu
des erreurs bien sûr qu'il y en a eu
beau y fiscal c'est à dire j'ai été un
des premiers à le dire vous voyez en
août 2014
je me souviens d'avoir tiré la sonnette
c'était en août 2013 pardon à voir si
celui-ci met quinze jours avant lui non
mais c'est m 15 autres proches me
souviens bon alors dites moi on a
compris donc quand même bien une
tonalité au secours la droite revient je
vous proposerai côté c'est par loncraine
parlons voilà enfin tchèque odien
seulement voilà puis seulement médecin
vous êtes également journaliste au fait
du fact checking jamais
ecoutez jean lil wayne est ce que dit
fabienne keller qui lé soutien d'alain
juppé sénatrice républicain du du bas
rhin elle vient s'exprimer au micro de
marie brémaud je crois que la gauche
s'est très largement discréditée au bout
de cinq années de présidence de françois
hollande
des promesses des paroles des actes
allant vers les promesses qu'ils avaient
formulées
je pense qu'ils sont pas très très bien
placée pour donner des leçons mais je
crois que ça a rendu ça modifie la
campagne présidentielle puisque le sujet
c'est de ne pas faire ce qui a été fait
c'est à dire de s'engager auprès des
français à des propositions réalistes
les propositions évaluer c'est possible
et nous préparons déjà d'ailleurs les
textes de mise en oeuvre concrète
même pas peur votre réaction je trouve
pas tout compris bon c'est un peu
général on va dire ouais bon voila j'ai
cru comprendre qu'elle n'aimait pas la
gauche elle soutient alain juppé
comment elles seront qui vous comment
expliquez vous que dans votre camp à
gauche alain juppé peut-être autant
neigé joron rien quand même et non mais
les voter à la primaire pour voter alain
juppé oui oui mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
des électeurs aux étroites qui vont
aussi et attendait parfois des électeurs
qui ont voté françois hollande ça a été
une grande erreur de la gauche de
considérer que les élections de 2012
c'est une victoire de la gauche
c'était une victoire de l'antisarkozysme
voilà ce qui est d'ailleurs peut-être un
peu court au canada juppé ça serait une
victoire de l'antisarkozysme aussi j'en
sais rien ça il faudra voir ce que ça va
donner je n'en sais rien je dis
simplement que en 2012 beaucoup de mes
amis ont fait l'analyse selon laquelle
la gauche avait gagné les élections
présidentielles la réalité je le crois
c'était que nous avions gagné par
antisarkozysme ce qui est premièrement
c'était donc une erreur d'alice
deuxièmement l'anti sarkozysme c'est un
peu court
voilà donc en termes de pensée politique
ça me paraît un peu court bien donc
je rappelle ça donc je lentilles gauche
me paraît aussi aujourd'hui un peu court
bond après que donc des électeurs qui
ont été déçus il y en a je vais pas le
nier veulent participer à la primaire de
la droite
voilà je le constate moi il ne faut pas
que ça y est très claire non je
maintiens pense que les gens je ne
comprendrais pas mais je n'imagine pas
les gens qui se disent de gauche qu'il
n'est pas l'ensemble des gens qui ont
voté pour nous je viens de le répéter il
y avait des gens et je souhaite
d'ailleurs que j'en ai beaucoup qu'ils
soient pas de gauche qui votent pour
nous moi je souhaite que les français
votent pour nous y a pas besoin d'un
passeport biologique pour voter pour le
banc donc je dis simplement qu'ils aient
des gens qui aient voté à un moment à
gauche qui aujourd'hui veulent aller je
le comprends que des gens qui se disent
de gauche et qui s'assume comme tel haï
signé un truc comme quoi ils sont de
droite et du centre je ne comprends pas
très bien merci merci merci monsieur le
ministre la semaine prochaine c'est jean
luc mélenchon qui sera notre invité on
interrogera sur la théorie du chaos ouen
lui prêter voilà merci à tous bon soir a
très vite